this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to audit.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like pressing code Joey
and get 10 off delivered right to your
house
what's happening you bad [__]
the joint is brought to you by
DraftKings listen it's Monday and this
week UFC 281 is live from New York
[__] City feel the heat of the
[__] octagon with DraftKings
Sportsbook the official sports betting
part of the UFC new customers you ready
for this one you're gonna bet five
dollars on UFC 281 and get 200 free bets
when you fight a wins if that's not
enough action for you everyone can earn
up to a thousand a hundred percent boost
with DraftKings stepped up ballets place
of parlay today with three or more picks
and combine multiple bets like which
fighter will win and total rounds this
week listen I got to take a look at this
again I got nobody I'm looking at you
know I wait I always wait until the
weigh-ins but DraftKings Sportsbook is
the only place your uncle boy Joey bets
on the UFC and don't forget those prop
bets download the DraftKings Sportsbook
app right now we got a whole new forget
the UFC we got the NFL we got Thursday
Night Football use promo code Joey and
throw five dollars on UFC 281 just five
dollars and get 203 bets when your
fighter wins that's code Joey this
Saturday at DraftKings Sportsbook the
official sports betting partner UFC
minimum age and eligibility restrictions
apply see show notes for details
download the DraftKings app right now
and get ready to [__] get paid laid
in parlayed this weekend listen the
joint is also brought to you by heart
and soil I've been trying to eat healthy
for the past few years after this little
thing I had at Princeton longevity I've
been taking these beef organ supplements
from heart and soul that [__]
tremendous you know what I'm doing a lot
better recuperating
beef organs are the more nutrient dense
than kale spinach and blueberries
combined that's why they're called
Nature's multivitamin
listen I've been taking them for three
weeks since I started when they came on
the show I feel a lot better I'm
sleeping a lot better I'm making pretty
good gains so I'm pretty happy people in
organs for thousands of years and never
suffer from obesity heart disease and
infertility because they were eating
organs Nature's Most treasured Foods
founded by Dr Paul saladino heart and
soul supplements are made from grass fed
grass finished beef organs feel like a
man when you take supplements made from
liver heart kidney spleen and testicles
let heart and soul help you reclaim your
[__] radical Health go to
arkansas.com
and use code Joey 10 for 10 off your
first order listen the holidays are
coming the New Year's coming you want to
be in [__] shape next year try at
heart and soul you won't be [__]
sorry off applies to one-time purchases
not subscriptions try them today and see
how they feel now let's get ready to get
this party started on a Monday morning
[Music]
check one two welcome to Uncle Joey's
Joy
[Music]
foreign
what up you bad [__] it's
Monday it's a whole new [__] month a
whole new set of rules was six weeks
away from [__] the holidays tricky
tricky is over Thanksgiving is two weeks
away and I'm [__] excited it was a
great weekend a lot of [__] happened I
want to congratulate the Houston Astros
for [__] winning the World Series I
caught the last inning of the game last
night I was busy all day I forgot that
we've been playing
and it's [__] weird man I'm still a
little kid at heart when I watch the I
watched the last out and I saw them all
jumping up and down and [__]
and I felt bad for Philly because Philly
played a great game they got the great
series great playoff run they got
nothing to be [__] embarrassed about
I can't wait to get down there [__]
to the show on the night before
Thanksgiving but
I was watching something like I'm still
like a [__] American wannabe
cause I'm sitting there and I saw the I
swear to God the [__] that gets me is
the dumbest [__] in the world but it
just lets you know that you're living in
the best country in the world man
the World Series is as American as can
be I can watch basketball I love
watching football you know I watch the
UFC whatever nothing gets me more than
like the World Series I don't know what
it is and I tell what else I like I like
the Final Four
something about the final four of those
young college kids winning and stuff
like that their moms in the [__]
audience you know like proud of their
kids that's always done something for me
because I didn't have parents but last
night during the World Series one of the
guys wanted us and his daughters were
out there with him and he was walking
with his daughters and they were [__]
happy and I'm like God damn I never get
to [__] do something like that I I
would love to do something like that I
still remember watching [__] Michael
Coran as a kid at the NCAA in 76
and going back to me like I love
stand-up comedy I love you know movie
stars Clint Eastwood and all that but to
me
like winning the NCAA and standing there
your parents in the [__] just
something and when I saw Mike o'conn he
was a Jersey City boy and I was a kid I
didn't think [__] New Jersey people
ever did anything I really didn't except
Sinatra you know so when I was watching
the semi-finals against UNLV that year
and they said oh corn was from New
Jersey I was like what the [__]
and then they said something about Saint
Anthony's I'm like Ah that's got to be a
difference in Anthony's in Jersey City
but that Monday night when they played
in the finals and I saw Jersey City New
Jersey
and [__] Saint Anthony's my head
Explorer as a little kid I never forgot
that and it's the same thing when I
watched the World Series last night when
they [__] were getting interviewed I
watched like 10 minutes I turned it off
before the kid got the MVP the 23 year
old kid but
you know what man baseball's over that
just lets you know we're close to the
[__] Thanksgiving and baseball went
all the way to [__] November this
year
November [__] 5th that's
that's [__] crazy but I want to thank
everybody who came out to the show
on Wednesday night I had a [__] blast
out there with uh
Felicia Lee Mike
it was great the people from DraftKings
came out like
you know
when I do the shows now my niece was
there George was there with [__] uh
his sister and her friend
the guys from laughing gas were there
the guys from Stoners clubs were there
listen man how about your neighbor yeah
the neighbors were there we gave him an
edible it was [__] great it really
was
and I do these shows and you know you
get into New York City like I'm not I
don't get excited until I'm in the
Lincoln Tunnel like it's great when I'm
on the three I see my grandma school I
see where the Iceman put the body into
the hotel I see all these things that
kind of bring me back a little bit
I [__] love it when I go into Lincoln
Tunnel I'm like I've been going through
that [__] tunnel it seemed like for a
hundred years when I come off that
tunnel and I'm headed into Jersey
I've been doing that since I was a
[__] kid man so
going into New York when you're going to
Lincoln Tunnel you know for a minute or
two you're like [__] one of one of these
bricks gonna [__] fall out and I'm
gonna be I'm gonna be like [__]
Earnest Poseidon Adventure
but then you get me energy in New York
City is [__] great and you know I
don't care how tired you are or whatever
as soon as you [__] get into New York
City there's just a buzz in here I was
watching Mike's video of him walking
through the city you know
listen man I've been everywhere and and
Nobody Does it Like New York City with
that energy when you're crossing the
street my whole [__] thing and it
stinks and there's a dead rat on the
floor that never happens anyway you know
so
we kept the Sony Hall and you know it
was [__] packed for Wednesday night
I think they oversold tickets I think I
had too many guests but holy [__] there
were people everywhere there was reefer
everywhere when you're on stage you see
everybody hitting the [__] vapor pens
one of the dudes from my patreon hit me
up and he goes Joey it's like being at a
dead concert
and it really feels like a dead concert
because you can't bomb
you can't bomb
listen I'm not having the best sets of
my life I'm trying new [__] out that you
know and you can't bomb you can't bomb
because there's so much love in the room
Lee got it
[__] uh
you know Felicia did great they were
happy to see Felicia George Perez
[__] did a great job stufina is
always a [__] trip
you know he really is a trip I love that
he shows up he just he's a great [__]
guy and he's out of his bird he really
is out of his bird
when we're downstairs talking after the
show [__] George showed up with
pastries oh that was from George they
were delicious oh my God I forget the
name of this place from Richfield Park
but they got the best lobster tails
everybody was walking around with a glob
of cream on their shirt that's why I
told Georgia to go George cut those
[__] lobster tail and have I saw Lee
bite into one and he had it all over his
[__] he had all of his beard and [__]
those lobster tails are so [__] good
the cannolis were on point you know I
had the chicken the chicken he brought
some chicken downstairs
they're just good fun nights can I do
all weekend of that now
I was so [__] tired on Thursday holy
[__]
and the party started on Tuesday night
with the mushrooms and the [__]
edibles
poor Lee thought he had a Lobster Claw
for a [__] hand he kept telling me
that at the restaurant he couldn't pick
up the dish and [__]
then we came back and we watched the
thief and you know Lee is a [__] trip
Wednesday night we came back we hung out
for like 10 minutes we were both wiped
out and [__] Thursday night holy [__]
Lee left till like 9 30 and I went right
to bed guys
I walked into the stairs he walked out I
had an option to come back and watch TV
and I was like I'm gonna at least try it
I went upstairs I hit the crib I don't
remember falling asleep all I remember
is being eight hours and [__] the uh
the [__] whoop Watts that's the
biggest sleep I've ever had I was just
tired those nights take a lot out of me
because I'm [__] you know I get
butterflies listen man I get butterflies
it's crazy
it
you never you always think when you're a
performer any type of performer whether
you're a magician whether you're a
[__] a musician
I love the butterflies I love being
scared and I love being focused I love
that feeling of the borderline puking I
I never guys I've never puked before set
but I've had a lot of dear friend Comics
that have puked they used to bark before
that sets I've never been that bad
but I tell you what man the butterflies
are just tremendous when you mix it with
the THC thank God lord had no mushrooms
in my system because the [__] stairs
you got to walk up and down stairs there
like two flights and whenever I eat
mushrooms I get winded for some reason
is that okay yeah I get [__] I don't
know like when I take the shroom Tech it
gives you a little bit of breeding room
but when I take psilocybin mushrooms no
matter whether they're mushrooms the
gummies whatever the [__] I take
I'm telling you man I I just have a hard
time breathing and then if I'm high by
the time I'm reaching for my breath I
start getting anxiety I don't like that
so I don't take the mushrooms till I get
off the stage once we get off that
[__] stage I stop popping those
silly mushrooms and I eat like four or
five of them just to set like I built my
tolerance to them now so I can eat a
whole bag my brother's eating a whole
bag at night he eats 10 [__] just to
[__] walk around in the afternoon but
you know what man I feel a lot better
since I'm eating the mushrooms I feel a
lot better since I'm micro dosing
I get better sleep I got a lot better
Clarity and uh that's all that [__]
matters man we're all right but I gotta
tell you what I did learn about
Wednesday night
which which really dawned on me in a
weird way
George Perez
George Perez listen I don't have to
watch you
I've been doing comedy for 30 [__]
years I've been studying comedy
I don't have to watch you I like sitting
behind the stage and listening
when I got into stand-up comedy I
listened I didn't ghost I was [__]
eight the first time I listened to a
stand-up comedy album that's how
stand-up was introduced to me it made
you sit down and listen
for years from the time I was
I don't know 10 11 until my mother died
that bedroom we would have listening
parties three times a week
people have in this country have
forgotten that
and there was so much [__] fun there
was so much [__] fun people forget
those listening parties and what it did
for certain people
listening parties are when people come
over like I don't know how many times on
Saturday nights I knew my mom was
working till three or four
and I get my friends at like [__]
seven we get like a
I don't know two six packs of beer two
two eight packs of nips you know
whatever the [__] they call them
and we'd drink them at a park or
something we'd get a nickel bag from
Puerto Rican Nelson we'd smoke seven out
of five uh five of the seven joints in
the nickel bag
we'd put Visine in our eyes we'd [__]
eat chips we'd [__] go to the diner
and [__] torture the waitress and
laugh in the face and then we'd shoot to
my house and we put on either a prior
album either a Led Zeppelin um
either an Earth Wind and Firearm I
remember nights we put on a couple
albums the albums in those days were
like Ted Nugent uh
not even double live Gonzo
I think it was Wang Dang Sweet Poontang
that I'm the live album or something oh
no it was Cat Scratch Fever that's what
we listened to we were just kids
but I had no idea I Was preparing myself
to listen
I loved it I loved you know in the 50s
you see all these people who would just
sit around radios and listen to The
Green Hornet there was no [__] TV
they listened and
for years I loved doing those listening
parties just
I still remember listening to Led
Zeppelin two of my buddies and being
[__] up and all of us standing up and
playing the air guitar and singing and
it was just the [__] you do when you're
on drugs but
I enjoyed those nights I enjoyed
listening I don't know well listen for
those Richard Pryor arms or red fox
albums with George Carl Mounds Lenny
Bruce Adams or Bob Newhart albums I
always enjoyed you could hear the energy
in the room what's going on in the
[__] room
like you can hear the waitresses you
could there's so much smoke in the room
it comes through the [__] speakers
like you could just feel it when you
really immerse yourself into what's
coming out of that anyway enough with
that [__]
so I'm sitting there listening to George
Perez's set
and I didn't even watch him just
his timing was [__] impeccable
George Perez's timing
was [__] impeccable
you know it was my show that night but
it was George Perez's night
and just
from a comic point of view
watching somebody improve that much I
mean I haven't seen George
I bumped you know when I went to LA I
saw George George and I talk all the
time I watched his podcast I watch his
[__] videos you know all the Mexican
stuff
and I see what he's doing in LA
and I know he's working hard as is
D'Agostino
my friend D'Agostino I heard is [__]
becoming a killer I hear Eric roaches
becoming a killer Lee is becoming a
little killer he's just finding his
[__] way but Lee is a very good
writer but to get back to George Perez
and what I learned that night for all
the young Comics that asked me questions
and whatnot this is always a good thing
on a Monday morning
I learned that while I was sitting there
first of all the comedy store
is still the best place in the world
to get your timing up I have never seen
that I remember walking into the comedy
store and years later people coming up
to me going Joey we haven't seen you in
18 months you're [__] timing your
timing your timing you know what timing
comes from listening
listening and I swear to God I did
thousands of shows and thousands of sets
but never in my life that I feel the
Improvement
from those three-minute spots on Sundays
those 15-minute spots during the week
you know having to bring up somebody
when you do a show you have an MC at The
Comedy Store you bring yourself up and I
don't mean power up on The Comedy Store
but when I hear somebody like George
Perez doing what he's doing I can't
think of anything else and I know George
works and I know George does he does a
lot of spots in other places the store
gives them three [__] but I heard
Ryan I saw a stand-up comedy uh
I saw Ryan's sickness stand up the other
day and I was like
Ryan has [__] improved a lot why they
all got past The Comedy Store in that
short period of time if you really
believe what you're doing in your sets
and you really comprehend what's going
on there's still listen
first time you start going up in the
store it's like going to Jujitsu it's
like doing anything else you're just
trying to [__] survive you're just
trying to survive you know like you you
know you're like I'm just gonna go up
there and try my best you try to survive
and you try not to [__] bomb when
you're a comic you know and then after a
couple weeks you start getting the hang
of it
but you don't get the hang of it we'll
get to that later you start getting the
hang of it
you don't even know what's really going
on you're very excited you're at the
you're regular at The Comedy Store
things are moving things are starting to
happen I might as well call [__] uh
Howard Stern and Tom to suck my dick
there's a new sheriff in town you get
all these thoughts on your head you're
excited but once that settles in you
start paying attention and you the good
thing about the store is when you do a
comedy uh set on the road like if I call
you call me tomorrow book me at the
stress Factory in Jersey Wednesday
through Saturday that's four nights
that's two six shows two on Friday
through Saturday and two during the week
right by the time
Friday comes Friday third show like uh
Friday early by the time Friday late
show comes along you're pretty loose
you've already known the room you know
the little you know what the headline is
going to do if he has a set list you
know what the MC's going to do if she
has a set list or he has a set list or
they have a set list just in case for
the people you know adjectives are big
now
for all these [__] things but when
you go to the store
The Improv the Laugh Factory if you go
up there four nights you're gonna see
four different Comics that's 16 Comics
you're gonna see if you stick around and
pay attention
you know some people just go on the back
and drink and whatever yeah that's what
I did too but I also paid attention I go
in there early like I tell people my
favorite thing in the world is to get
stoned to the gills in the [__] car
walk into the original room go all the
way in the back where me and Jason Lucas
used to sit not in the mitzi's chairs
but all the way in the back back there
where nobody would even interrupt your
wife [__] sit in one of these chairs
somebody's gonna come and paying
customers gonna come during the week
said all the way in the back the last
row back then the dungeon if you put on
the black sweatshirt nobody even knows
you're [__] man that's how great that
is you're sit in the back and watch four
or five comics and you learn so much now
you're watching and you're incorporating
the listening aspect of it but here's
the beauty of all this that I learned
from George Perez that I've said for
[__] years and I told you why
when people come to see my shows now
when people hit me up on emails I'm like
Joey we really come see you we want to
get sets I'll tell them right off the
bat listen guys
you're not losing out anything
you're not losing out anything trust me
I'm telling you this comic there's young
Comics out there that are [__]
killing it right now that you don't know
who the [__] they are it's time that you
got the [__] know
uh Jimmy Florentine was in uh
whatever the [__] last week
he was at in Austin last week he went to
the Vulcan on Thursday night and I saw
the pictures online
and I saw that three or two floors at
the Vulcan I've never been in there
but there were people hanging off the
[__] Raptors
holy [__]
the next day I called him when he was in
Dallas and he was like Joey what I
witnessed yesterday was [__]
tremendous
he goes I saw a bunch of young comics
that are [__] going for it
like they're just [__] going for it
they're saying [__] up jokes that
talking about weird [__] on stage and
they don't give a Frenchman's [__] and
the audiences are eating it up that's
and he goes not like in New York where
people are playing to the audiences and
L.A where people are playing through the
audiences LA and New York have already
put in the
the uh
the uh woke implementations a lot of
clubs are a booking uh just woke Comics
you know just they're doing shows to
make people giggle instead of Heavy
Hitters and people who say weird things
I'm okay with that you know
but it was really good for Jimmy to say
that he goes if I was a young comic
right now I'd come here because there
are you know 20 million places to do
comedy and you're watching Comics you're
you're [__] you're living snorting
chewing eating sleeping [__] comedy
and that's what I'm getting to right now
you know when I was sitting back there
listening to George
and I tried new material this week it
worked I've been trying to polish it up
a little bit but during the week guys
listen like I told George like a George
my life has changed a lot
for me to [__] put my sneakers on at
night and go do this app
it's not working for me and I talked to
a good friend of mine uh Rob Rob
Schaefer we went out to lunch last week
before he went to uh Miami
and we were talking about training at
night how for a while I was doing okay
now I wasn't going to Jujitsu at night I
was just going to the gym at night one
night a week I said I'm gonna go to the
gym and do a pretty [__] decent
workout 45 minutes ride the bike and I
stuck to it I stuck to it so I went down
to the ob and then when I came back from
the Outer Banks you know [__] got crazy
with girls softball practice on Tuesdays
game on Wednesday so I lost it and I
still go to the gym one night a week
even if it's just to ride the bike I go
to the gym I do a couple down with dogs
I do [__] like that but I told him like
I gotta start going to I got to change
my life around I got to start going to
Jujitsu at night and he goes listen I
know you don't like it but go
just go Wednesday nights make a goal to
go one night a week
and start small he goes because see the
the night classes you could participate
in all three classes should be a
tremendous workout I'm just an old man I
don't have no energy at night but I have
to just start going to the core classes
at night and those are the classes where
you don't roll and then
do it slowly even though I'm tired you
know just go take the chances but anyway
that's got nothing to do with what we're
talking about here
you know at night I just like staying
there with my family [__] so many
years I always had to go somewhere at
night that now it's kind of [__] nice
this week I'm thinking uh my family has
to go to Pennsylvania for a [__]
softball tournament if I don't go with
them like Friday night I want to go see
poor visi Paul's at distress Factory
this weekend uh Tom pop is at Red Bank
on Saturday night I was thinking of
going maybe going to get a bite with him
in Red Bank or maybe he comes here and
we'll go to El Nino or cousins or
something I don't know I don't know
but I need to start going out during the
week not even to do comedy how about
let's start with getting [__]
entertained
that's a lot of people forget you got to
get [__] entertained you know my
nights suck so but I'm sitting there
listening to George
and this applies to everybody you know
guys
until 2007 from 2002 to 2007.
I would get harassed
constantly
constantly and it was
the weirdest form of harassment I had
maybe
eight or nine comedians
a to nine of them
that would call me once a week and tell
me how bad that life was going
and me being the nice guy that I am I
would talk to him about you know dog you
know you just gotta hang in there we're
in L.A this is the major leagues I mean
I'm not doing any better than you but at
the time I was booking like TV shows
like I was booking like Mad TV and I had
done Analyze That where I had three
lines and got shot but for some reason
when I was getting those rolls these
guys were thinking like you know I was
getting ahead of my life and to me those
roles didn't mean [__] it was just
getting experience
but these guys would call me and like
put guilt trips on me like dog I don't
know what the [__] is going on I never
get a movie I never get a TV show I
never got a guy like Rogan to take me on
the road you know well I tell you what I
never asked Joe to take me on the road I
would get on stage 11 45 every night and
if he had his set I had a set and
eventually he decided I was a hard
worker and he gave me the opportunity to
open up on the road these uh stupid TV
shows I'm getting and stuff like that I
get them because I go to acting class I
believe in it I work at and I get an
opportunity and I learned how to finally
be bro you got to remember from 97 to
[__] 2002 I auditioned three times a
[__] week I didn't get [__] I felt
like [__] taking a Swan Dive many a
night but I got to the source I got into
acting class and started meeting people
and talking to other [__] people and
see what they were doing I got into
acting class to see What actors would do
to hospital work
and I learned how to [__] hustle
acting work I started putting auditions
on tape we got the longest yard in
American Gangster and all these stupid
[__] movies
but I didn't get those movies because I
don't know I got them because I was
working and see while everybody was
talking [__] about me Joey D is a Coke
fiend Joey Diaz is this Joey Diaz is
that that's what got to them more that
they couldn't figure out what I was
doing well I'll tell you what I was
doing I was working it I was working it
well I was sitting there listening to
George Perez and thinking what he was
putting into it I still remember me Josh
Wolf and Ralphie May
chipping in for [__] you know a lunch
between the three of us and maybe my
envelope was lighting the boat that ass
and us talking about what we were doing
and Joshua's writing and Ralphie May was
at the lab Factory and I'm taking stupid
acting classes I would give my life
to be back to that situation again
when you're a hustling [__] comic
when you're getting up at [__] nine
and your whole I mean listen I used to
get up at nine there was no I would
never be at some coffee shop [__]
giggling or hanging out with other
Comics or playing frisbee or smoking
dope or I did that I could count on my
hands how many times I did that [__] we
worked man I got a call from a friend of
mine and he was telling me hey man I
didn't know me George Perez Silent Bob
Felipe esparz or Rick Ramos we used to
have our own acting class
we all went to acting classes we saw
what the [__] they did in acting class
and we could do the same thing so every
Tuesday for about a year we would meet
on Tuesdays do a pseudo acting class
outside of the [__] Park
and then go get super [__] stoned and
buy Edibles and but we understand we put
in the [__] work you know Felipe
Willie Barcena Rudy Moreno I mean these
guys
you know Marilyn Martinez gotta rest his
soul her anniversary was last week these
[__] people were out not every night
not every night
every minute
every minute I still remember
I didn't listen I stopped going to
weddings and functions and bars and [__]
because
honestly I didn't want to talk about
your stupidity all I wanted to talk
about was comedy and how to get better
that's all I had on my [__] mind
there was no when Mike would come up to
me do you know what me and Mikey did
this weekend I really don't give a [__]
you know what I'm saying kids are the
last thing in my mind and I don't want
to hear about [__] kids and I lost a
lot of friends from not doing certain
functions and going to weddings and
going to sporting events and stupid
parties and back to parties but in
retrospect I didn't give a [__]
because I didn't move out there to do
all that [__] I moved out there to work
on my craft and my point being the
reason why George Perez improved so much
and guys
this runs across the board
talking about calmly but this runs if
you're a plumber a guitar player a
writer a [__] Movie Editor the whole
thing you know how many [__] people
would call me and say different things
to me and I would always ask them the
same thing
what did you do last week
and all these people that used to call
me like how I stopped from them calling
me how I stopped getting these people to
call me I didn't [__] ever yell at
them and go get the [__] work
I would say to them what'd you do last
week
well my sister had a birthday party in
Laguna Beach and I went down there for
three days ah
when you were down Laguna Beach did you
do any sets
do you think of going through that
contest nah we were partying and having
a good time all right what'd you do
Thursday when you came back oh [__]
uh Johnny had a [__] barbecue
combination party at his backyard we did
come here okay what'd you do Friday I
went to a movie with my girlfriend
what'd you do Saturday night
Saturday I had a show and [__] an AAA
meeting okay listen so what you're
telling me is you got on stage two times
you live in Hollywood you live in L.A
and you're telling me you got on stage
two [__] times well
how many times I got on stage last week
and granted I'm a fat [__]
um 360 pounds I'm snorting coke I'm
broke
I got on stage
22 times last week
what do you mean but see you know people
your friends are broken
don't put Rogan into the [__]
equation Monday I started a Latino night
then I went over and did an open mic at
the [__] comedy store and then from
there I got in my car and I Met George
Perez down in [__] a bar we used to
do on Monday nights that the open mic
started at 11.
we wouldn't get home till two in the
[__] morning there was a Chinese
restaurant that wouldn't serve us
because we were in Chinese gangsters
there was a donut place I mean dog we
would eat chicken wings from this bar
that when you would bite into them you
could see the veins in the oh my God you
have no [__] idea what we put up with
and then we got home at eight and I got
up in the mornings and I looked at
breakdowns and then from there I [__]
smoked pot and I did this and I put
auditions on tape and then we went to
the car Tuesday night was a [__] you
know was African-American night The
Comedy Store you go down there hustle to
get a spot what I'm trying to say is
whether you're a plumber whatever the
[__] you do if you're gonna grow doing
something
you have to live it chew it sniff it
fart it [__] it suck it you got to do
everything to this [__] thing if not
listen it might work out for you
but believe me between you and me it's
not going to how do I know because of
what's going on with my life right now
when I go on stage yeah I'm funny I'm
writing I got new jokes but
it's not the Joey Diaz that was going on
stage two nights or two nights of
[__] night two times a night
three four years ago it's not the Joey
Diaz that was doing a comedy podcast
constantly surrounding himself with you
know America's best comics and your mind
is always thinking I don't have that
mind no more I've been saying that for a
week yeah I cracked funny jokes but I'm
driving around I I get giggle when I get
high [__] like that but to have that
[__] machine gun mind that constantly
you got to work that thing every day
it's a [__] muscle like anything else
so if you're a [__] lawyer and you're
just doing a bare minimum and then five
years from now you're like how come
nobody makes me apart no well the guy in
the other room Works face [__] has a
cotton here
and on the weekends he goes to
conferences and he learns about the new
[__] miracle marijuana laws or
whatever the [__] and even though like I
didn't want to be an actor but I didn't
want to get in a [__] set years from
there and not know what I was going to
do I never thought I'd get in the big
movie but guess what I ended up in one
maybe because I had the confidence when
I walked in that room to nail that
[__] set to some people like oh well
Joey's gay he must have sucked his dick
Rogan must have called him yes that's
the easy way out that's what people
don't know the [__] business would
say that's the easy way out you got to
work it and yes I got help from Rogan
and yes I got help from Dane Cook and
yes I got help from Ralphie May and yes
I got help from Gabriel Iglesias but
during that whole [__] time guess
what I was doing I was helping myself
I'd met so many young Comics the last
eight years that basically want you to
do the [__] work from
and that's not gonna happen I know five
times six is 30. you know what [__]
show me the [__] work show me the
goddamn paper I know four times eight is
32 but you know what let's break it down
show me where you carried the one you
did the whole [__] thing I don't
think anybody wants to do that today
and you know
I applaud those young guys in Austin I
applaud Joe Rogan that he's chasing it
he kills it every opportunity that he
can you know for me and my world things
you know I just saw Bert was 50 this
week good for bird I got to call him and
wish him a happy birthday I wrote a
thing on there but I got to call him
anyway
it's funny he's 50 at 50. I was stabbing
[__] you guys know me at 50 I
was stabbing [__] 10 years ago
I had the energy of 10 bulls that hit my
[__] chase them but I'm getting to a
part of my life right now that
I don't even know if I want to [__]
chase it I enjoy doing it when I do it
but
listen I don't want to get on a plane I
enjoy showing up to Uncle Vinny's and I
enjoy maybe Friday night going to Saint
Paul Vision if he asked me to do a spot
maybe I'll go up there maybe you know
what the [__] I never know but I like
that
I liked that for years I lived I [__]
hated after my daughter was born that I
go to a party and I had to leave in 10
minutes I got to leave now now I could
just settle I did my time I did what I
had to do and it's just a [__] Hobby
and I got no qualms with it but I want
people to know that if you want to
improve in any aspect of something if
you want to [__] be the king of that
nothing's gonna work part-time I'm
telling you right now it's not gonna
work part-time it's your heart and your
[__] soul that you got to put into
this [__] and I tell you what think
about this podcast
um
2023 you gotta up in a little bit guys
they're not [__] the bluebird
happiness ain't even coming around like
that [__] used to anymore and
you guys know and feeling so you gotta
up in a little bit you're working 50
hours maybe you got to work 60. maybe
not work 60 maybe work 50 and learn
about what you're doing 10 hours a week
take a [__] class but submit you you
know indulge yourself in this [__] it's
got to be over your head dog I got
dunked by two women who were like
you know there's something wrong with
you
you like [__] comedy more than [__]
no I like comedy comedy was first and
cocaine was the second [__] was a
close tie and [__] was second but when
I was [__] hunting from 80 from 95
to
2019 when the pandemic came I hunted
Jack it was not a part-time thing it was
not a haha he he there was no back to
parties there was no trips to the
Bahamas there was no there was nothing
my for me for me that's the only way it
worked it didn't work by me doing a half
so if your career is staggering whatever
it could be you're a plumber a Mason a
[__] electric you know whatever the
[__] it is maybe take a look at yourself
maybe you're not putting enough effort
into this [__] game
pretty [__] cool for a Monday [__]
morning and guess what else [__]
the movie I was doing is canceled
[Music]
am I depressed
listen guys
things happen in your life and
the projects come and [__] go it's
just this was the craziest year that
I've ever had for [__] acting the
last three months from auditions to how
they went down and you know what that
was
I'm pretty much done for the year
probably with auditions I'll probably
get maybe one more maybe two more who
the [__] knows I don't give a [__] uh
yeah That's Amore got shut down for a
few weeks
financing issues whatever who the [__]
knows I uh
now have no goals you know I was going
to be tight I don't even think we I
think I looked at the schedule we were
only going to be able to do one podcast
a week there was no way there was no way
we could do too because I was working
every Tuesday when except Thanksgiving
week I have off but it was it was going
to be like that until December 15th so
everything happens for a reason I'm not
sad about it something else will come up
you know I didn't get the dinero movie
and that came up and that's it guys and
that's another listen that's why I was
thinking about the effort you put into
things you know I'm not an acting class
I'm not talking to actors every day
about what's going on or different
auditions or whatever like that so when
you do get an audition now you're
[__] Rusty as [__] so I learned
something about me auditioning this time
and now I gotta take a little bit more
time
look at the you know I I can't see
anymore so I have to use a teleprompter
when I do the auditions you know I look
at the auditions and I'm like [__]
staring at the teleprompter you know you
can't find the teleprompter like I have
sometimes I use one of these stands I
hang the computer up and do it it's not
gonna [__] work you gotta know these
computers yeah no you got to know the
you got to know the lines inside now so
but hey it's Monday the 7th to [__]
November tomorrow is uh election day
what advice I don't give a [__] who you
vote for just get out there and vote
that's all the advice that people say go
out there and vote I you know I can't
vote by the time I do the process I
called the I spoke to the attorney a
year ago about me uh
you know wiping my police record down
and that was about a year ago that's the
last time I heard from my I saw him at
some party how you doing I was gonna ask
him about whatever happened with that
call but I figured out you have to
everybody who's like the D.A they got to
hunt them down and say hey 25 years ago
you convicted a kid on second degree
burglary do you want to flip it you'll
go let me think about it forget it I'll
just stay with the record no jury duty
who gives a [__] don't forget UFC this
weekend big one DraftKings has a deal
for you that's it and that's that I love
your [__] suck to stay black and I'll
see you Thursday morning Dip Top Magoo
all right you bad [__] I want
to thank you today we got a little short
podcast but it's Monday you got things
to do and so the [__] do I the joint is
brought to you by heart and soil beef
organs are more nutrient dense than kale
spinach and blueberries combined nobody
knows that that's why they're called
Nature's multivitamin I've been taking
these for three weeks and I'm feeling a
lot better what improved is my
recuperation my sleep
uh founded by Dr Paul saladino heart and
soul supplements are made from grass-fed
finished beef organs people ate organs
for thousands of years and never
suffered from obesity heart disease or
infertility because they're weed and
organs Nature's more treasured food feel
like a man when you take supplements
made from liver heart kidney and spleen
and density
let heart and soul help you reclaim your
Birthright the radical Health go to
Heart and Soul dot Co dot C dot o and
you or Dash o and use code Joey 10 for
10 off your first order that's heart and
soul dot Capital C Dash capital O and
use code Joey 10. for 10 off your first
order offer applies to one-time
purchases the joint is also brought to
you by [__] DraftKings the best the
king of prop bets the ufcs here this
weekend 281 out of the big bad
[__] Apple
right now but five dollars let me fight
in a wedding when he comes in you get
200 free bets that's great and dandy but
what are you gonna do with your 200 free
bets you got prop bet you got the over
and under you got how they're gonna
[__] win or lose disqualification
knockout submission listen sometimes I
just love playing the prop bets on art
on DraftKings so do yourself a favor
download the DraftKings Sportsbook app
today
let's have some fun with UFC 281 if you
don't like single action you could bet
the same game Paula listen they're so
good DraftKings only lets you do one a
day but everybody can earn up to 100
boost with DraftKings stepped up parlays
listen DraftKings Sportsbook is the only
place Uncle Joey bets on the UFC so do
yourself a favor download the DraftKings
Sportsbook app today use promo code Joey
and throw down five dollars on UFC 281
and get 200 and free bets if you fight a
win wins that's coach Joey this Saturday
at DraftKings Sportsbook write the
master Square guard and don't forget
DraftKings the official sports betting
part of the UFC minimum age and
eligibility restrictions apply she show
notes for details I want to thank you I
want to thank DraftKings and I want to
thank heart and soul dot Capital C slash
capital O I love you [__] have
a great Monday have a great week and
we'll see you Thursday morning Tip Top
Magoo
[Music]